[Musique]
l'expérience que je voudrais vous
proposer aujourd'hui et de voyager à la
frontière des deux hémisphères de notre
cerveau réconcilier ce qu' a priori tout
oppose
avec d'un côté l'hémisphère gauche dédié
à la logique à la raison et l'hémisphère
droit qui est plutôt liée aux émotions
et à la créativité
alors quand certains disent on travaille
avec un pinceau on va dire que moi ma
façon de travailler ce serait plutôt
utiliser la programmation informatique
il se trouve que je suis un scientifique
spécialisé dans tout ce qui est big data
chaque ça fait un petit peu peur en ce
moment c'est pas la bonne période ce qui
est intelligence artificielle ça fait
encore plus peur est ce que je vais
quand certains peignent avec de la
peinture
moi ça va être plutôt avec des données
alors qu'est ce que c'est des données
informatiques
je pense qu'on est tous plus ou moins
familiers avec le terme de données on
peut dire que c'est des valeurs qu'on
pourrait rentrer dans un tableau excel
par exemple là je prends l'assemblée je
peux vous demander votre nom votre âge
votre profession d'où vous venez et
prêché peut stocker ces informations
directement dans mon ordinateur dans une
base de données donc si on prend
l'analogie avec la peinture
on va dire que les données ça serait
plutôt les pigments et pour qu'un
peintre puisse peindre il a besoin de
lier ces pigments alors à l'époque
c'était avec du jaune d'oeuf
maintenant on utilise des huiles de
synthétique pouvoir créer à partir des
pigments de la peinture et moi de la
même manière pour pouvoir peindre avec
m'est donnée je vais avoir besoin de
données de les lier ensemble et pour ça
je vais utiliser ce qu'on appelle un
réseau un réseau de données alors c'est
encore un terme qui peut paraître
compliqué mais en fait je pense qu'on
est tous plus ou moins familiers avec le
terme de réseau on parle bien d'un
réseau routier un réseau électrique un
réseau social un réseau mafieux un
réseau terroriste est une façon de
représenter un réseau une façon
graphique de leur présenter c'est
d'utiliser des points et des lignes je
vous ai montré ici
deux exemples d'une partie de la carte
du métro de new york où on a bien les
stations de métro qui sont des points
reliés ensemble
des lignes qui sont les lignes de métro
donc ça c'est une déjà une
représentation graphique d'un réseau si
je prends l'exemple d'un réseau social
moi je me suis mis ici en rouge et je
vois que je suis connecté à certains
amis qui peuvent avoir des amis en
commun avec moi et ou en connaître
d'autres amis que je ne connaisse pas et
que je ne connais pas et qu'au final
finalement si on lit deux objets
quelconques ensemble c'est déjà le début
d'un réseau petit réseau mais c'est déjà
un réseau donc on a notre réseau à
chaque vous allez me dire ou es
c'est un petit peu compliqué en tout cas
ça va être un outil qui alla très
puissant mathématiquement mais c'est pas
très beau mais c'est encore moins dollar
alors j'ai besoin avant d'arriver là
j'ai besoin encore d'une dernière
analogie alors je voudrais qu'on
s'attarde un petit peu sur 7 sur cette
fleur et j'espère que elle nous procure
de l'émotion c'est qu'elle est allée à
ses belles femmes et des belles couleurs
et messi ont dit zuma l'inde air de
cette fleur finalement on se rend compte
que qu'est-ce que ça une fleur
c'est un agencement d'atomes s'ils ont
vraiment on descendre infiniment petit
qu'on peut lier entre eux et qui forme
des molécules par exemple il ya
forcément des molécules d'eau dans cette
fleur qu'est ce que c'est les molécules
d'eau c'est un atome d'oxygène qui est
lié à un atome d'hydrogène et qu'il est
un autre atomes d'hydrogène h2 o donc
finalement ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que à partir d'un réseau qui
est tout à fait banale on se rend compte
que la nature en suivant des modèles
physiques et des propriétés qu'on arrive
à décrire avec des modèles mathématiques
peut nous donner et nous générer de
l'émotion comme on voit ici c'est une et
finalement une histoire d'échelle donc
c'est intéressant de voir est ce que
finalement en imitant la nature on peut
arriver à susciter de l'émotion
en étudiant exactement les mêmes
techniques sauf que de prendre des
atomes on prendrait des données ça c'est
un peu la question qui m'a que je vous
pose et qu'on va essayer de voir
ensemble est-ce qu'on peut créer de
l'aimé vraiment avec un bilan comptable
qui a priori par le truc le plus
artistique haine de la terre est ce
qu'on peut susciter de l'émotion avec un
annuaire téléphonique
on n'a plus trop maintenant mais
voyez-vous l idée
alors cette heure que j'ai appelés quand
la musique est bonne en fait elle
utilise justement les mêmes propriétés
que ce qu'on retrouve dans cette fleur
c'est les mêmes modèles mathématiques et
physiques qui sont basés sur
l'attraction débattre des particules
donc les forces de la nature et ce qu'on
voit ici le devoir des atomes chaque
point représente un artiste qui est qui
a joué au montreux jazz festival
lorsque vous connaissez je pense que
certains d'entre vous connaissent le
montreux jazz qui incarne un grand
festival de musique il est parti du jazz
à l'époque il ya plus de 50 ans et il
s'est progressivement étendue à d'autres
genres de musique mais à chaque fois il
ya toujours eu des artistes de renommée
mondiale qui sont venus ici je vous ai
montré queen mais à princeton king
michael jackson qui est venu aussi va
vraiment d'aider des gros calibres
d'artistes et ski particulier avec le
montreux jazz c'est que c'est connu ce
festival est connu pour que les artistes
viennent sur scène et fasse des des jam
sessions stade qui viennent ensemble
qu'ils invitent des invités qu'on
n'avait pas forcément prévu qu'ils
jouent les concerts peuvent durer deux
heures trois heures c'est interminable
des fois parce que les gens ils
partagent vraiment avec le public et ce
qui est donc ce que j'ai voulu montrer
dans ce tableau en fait c'est de lier
les artistes justement si l'on joué
ensemble sur scène c'est typiquement
propres à l'univers du jazz comme vous
pouvez le voir il ya vraiment deux
grandes catégories d'artistes
on a à la bordure du cercle tous ceux
qui ont joué avec leurs groupes qui sont
pas forcément mélanger ils peuvent être
très populaire mais il reste à la
bordure est au centre
vraiment les stars du festival avec par
exemple tout ce qui est en jaune la
communauté autour de bb king
santana en violet ou encore giorgio camp
orange qui est un grand pianiste jazzmen
qui a le plus de participations montreux
jazz avec plus de 53 l'apparence donc
c'est que beaucoup de beaucoup de
données qu'on arrive à d'avoir traité
est a priori si vous donnez un listing
du montreux jazz tue pas super c'était
pas évident d'arriver à cette
augmentation là parce qu'il a fallu
analyser les données et après l'ailier
faire un réseau alors je devrai
continuer sur cette idée intéressante on
progresse un petit peu dans la
réalisation de artistique de voir que
l'on peut s'éloigner un petit peu des
modèles physiques traditionnelles et
après arriver à mélanger
de plus en plus de modèles pour arriver
à des formes qui sont qui n'existent pas
vraiment dans la nature et cet exemple
là il me parle parce qu'en fait on peut
être tous finalement acteurs d'un réseau
c'était un peu l'idée de l'idée de base
mais il ya deux choses qu'on n'a pas
droit de changer quand on veut
représenter de manière graphique et
s'amuser avec les données ont tout
changé les couleurs on peut choisir de
la position dans l'espace mais on a il
ya deux choses qu'on n'a pas droit de
faire on n'a pas le droit d'ajouter ou
d'enlever un point parce que ça veut
dire si on prend l'analogie avec notre
fleurs que j'enlèverai des atomes ou que
l'on mettrait dedans donc c'est un peu
bas et les liens c'est pareil c'est les
liaisons chimiques et ça c'est lien ici
sont donnés par les jeux de données donc
moi j'ai pas d' influence directe sur ce
que je peux faire par rapport au point
et howling par contre je peux choisir
quels modèles qu'elle algorithmes
qu'elle provoque
comment je vais programmé pour changer
finalement la représentation visuelle et
cet exemple là il est parlant pas bon
parce que ils montrent la collaboration
entre les anciens jeux ce point entre
les chercheurs de l'université donc
j'étais avant et il se trouve que moi
aussi je suis dedans tu t'en bas alors
je sais pas si vous voyez bien dans le
groupe
violet un côté du paquet ou jaune et on
fait chaque chercheur est lié à ses
anciens collègues donc enfin mais mes
anciens collègues et ce qu'on voit ici
c'est tous les domaines de recherche de
le pfl où j'ai étudié
donc on a lié les allées les chercheurs
si l'on co publié un article
scientifique ensemble donc c'est aussi
intéressante de se regarder le tableau
parce qu'on voit que déjà à tout est
connecté
ça veut dire que si je pars de la
microbiologie qu'on a eu plus de plus
tôt et que je veux me connecter à
l'informatique ou mécanique etc
j'ai toujours un lien ya toujours un
prof qui a vu un étudiant qui a
collaboré avec machin qui s'est connecté
etc et qui fait que finalement pour
rejoindre dans quelques sauts tous les
domaines de recherche
en tout cas de cette université c'est un
message qui est assez positif mais
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas forcément
tous chercheurs donc ça vous n'êtes pas
forcément à claire de ce réseau donc je
voudrais vous proposer un autre réseau
qui va peut-être vous plus vous parlez
je fais un petit sondage qui s'est déjà
retrouvé bloqué dans une gare en
attendant son train
c'est pas ça tombe bien qu'ils étaient
grève en ce moment je n'ai pas forcément
prévu on a eu un intervenant hier où le
ter a pris feu donc voilà et ce alors ce
tableau il est il est intéressant parce
que il est basé sur des données de la
gare de lausanne
ce qu'on a fait dans la gare de lausanne
c'est qu'on a mis des caméras il y avait
environ 70 caméra qui traquait les
positions de tous les gens de manière
anonyme dans le but de fluidifier le
trafic
justement d'éviter les congestions de
train et ce qu'on voit là en fait tous
ces petits sous réseau c'est la
congestion et c'est des gens fait qu'ils
sortent du train qui arrive pas à
rentrer et qui essayent de dalé de
rejoindre inquiets ou de sortir donc
c'est tout la congestion dans la gare de
lausanne donc on voit que chaque point
c'est de la congestion puis en fait ils
sont reliés parce qu'il sait d'avancé
donc on voit qu'ils peuvent tourner dans
des couloirs à gauche à droite et c'est
ce qui est intéressant dans notre cas ce
qui me plaît dans ce réseau c'est qu'il
illustre bien un peu la mécanique
quotidienne de millions de personnes qui
prennent les transports chaque jour et
qui donne peut-être j'espère en tout cas
une image un petit peu plus positive du
big data
parce que là l'idée c'est quand même que
la vie des usagers soit facilité qu'on
puisse fluidifier le trafic etc
c'est pas toujours ce qu'on entend dans
les médias
j'ai aussi deux est convaincu mais
j'essaie c'est bon c'est mon boulot
alors un autre exemple peut-être que
vous connaissez qui est un peu moins de
courant dues du big data
c'est d'essayer de ré explorer notre
histoire une histoire collective de la
civilisation à travers le monde ces
données et comment on fait pour ça on a
besoin déjà de récupérer de digitaliser
c'est à transformer les anciens
manuscrits en latin et en grec etc
en données informatiques donc il ya déjà
un problème c'est que la plupart du
temps c'est l'image qui sont trop
anciens
le simple fait de lait déroulé on les
détruit donc les humanités digital donc
les groupes de chercheurs qui
travaillent dans ces dans ces domaines
là sont obligés de fait de faire appel à
plein de domaines différents avec de la
physique avec des mâts de l'informatique
etc pour essayer de lire l'information
sans la détruire
transformé en corpus digital et ensuite
essayer de l'analyser donc c'est
intéressant parce qu'on pourrait
explorer les relations marchandes
de venise par exemple les conflits du
moyen âge les mouvements des troupes etc
etc
mais en attendant d'avoir stocké de
pouvoir vraiment analyser toutes ces
données à une échelle massive
on peut quand même déjà s'entraîner à
développer des outils qui permettent
d'explorer justement les relations entre
les personnages sur un corpus qui est
fictionnelle alors ce tableau qui
s'appelle le côté obscur et la lumière
non je ne sais pas s'il ya des gens qui
sont familiers avec star wars - me vous
quand même et il se trouve que star wars
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
je sais pas c'est l'univers fictionnel
le plus grand jamais créés
collectivement par l'humanité pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée ici on a
représenté tous les personnages de
l'univers étendu de star wars et terre
les films les livres les jeux vidéo il
ya juste 850 livres qui ont été écrits
sur star wars donc c'est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup et il ya vingt mille
personnages dans cet univers quant aux
noms qui ont une description du
biographique l'état ils sont liés
ensemble si justement il qu apparaisse
dans la biographie de chaque personnage
exactement comme si on lisait les
mémoires d'un monarque qu'on pourrait
trouver dans un livre en latin par
exemple donc on voit ici par exemple en
rouge le côté obscur les sites et en
blanc en bleu
la rébellion les gentils donc pas si
vous voyez bien mais il ya le gros point
combat au milieu c'est dark vador le
grand emblématique donc c'est vraiment
des chaque mois ce n'est pas juste une
vue d'artiste on peut cliquer dessus et
avoir les données qui sont associés à
chaque chaque point donc ça c'est une
autre une autre application du big data
et ça m'a donné un petit peu l'idée de
dire vu que c'est un corpus qu'on a
créés collectivement
est ce que serait pas aussi intéressant
d'étudier le comportement des
internautes aussi en ligne puisque c'est
on finalement ça a été créé à partir
d'un site web est ce que je voudrais
vous présenter là c'est environ un an de
recherche sur wikipédia
on a eu un petit peu auparavant donc ça
c'est pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
c'est 5 milliards de visites sur
wikipédia angles donc ça change un petit
peu des études statistiques on entend
sur 1000 personnes redressé au quota là
c'est vraiment
quantitatif il ya vraiment 5 milliard de
visites et l'idée c'est de comprendre
comment les gens vont sur wikipédia
quels sont les comment ils se déplacent
à travers ces pages
quels sont les sujets qui sont
finalement les plus visités et ce qu'on
voit ici donc je sais pas si vous voyez
bien mais le réseau en fait c'est tout
les petites ou les pétales de cette
espèce de fleur en fait c'est tout les
points qu'on a que j'ai mis les uns à la
suite des autres ils sont organisés par
grands sujets il a été extrait de
manière complètement automatique par les
visites des gens donc un point c'est un
groupe de pages qui a été vue de manière
significative et sont liés ensemble
s'ils partagent une page par exemple
trump il serait à la fois d'un politique
et showbiz
parce qu'ils étaient avant quelques
minutes showbiz donc il pourrait relier
ces deux pétales et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de dire ok maintenant
qu'on a récupéré toutes ses visites
quels sont les sujets qui sont les plus
vu en moi je pensais naïvement que vous
qui pda ce serait le la connaissance
avec un grand c je vais sur wikipédia
pour m'instruire et qui rigole mais en
fait
wikipedia c'est pas exactement ça on
s'est rendu compte que 80 % des visites
en fait elle était liée à tout ce qu'on
appelle entertainment showbiz série
américaine sport et qu'en fait la
connaissance c'est pas du tout
significatif est donc en bonne voie
comme on le voit dans ce tableau je sais
pas s'il ya un pétale qui est de cartes
qui est très très dense qui est un petit
peu en bas à droite de l'image est
celui-là il correspond par exemple à
toutes les séries américaines c'est qui
est le sujet de très loin le plus vu sur
wikipédia et on fait tout ça si on y
réfléchit bien je tape un film je trouve
l'acteur principal ah il est marié avec
machin qui est une actrice qui on passe
tous du temps sur wikipédia comme ça et
c'est on veut bon n'est pas seul à faire
ça c'est significatif donc voilà des
plusieurs millions de visites là dessus
et moi ce qui m'a choqué un petit peu
dans cette analyse c'est que finalement
l'actualité scientifique ou la commenter
la science en général était pas du tout
représentatif mais pas du tout
significatif et du coup je me suis posé
la question est ce que c'est parce que
les scientifiques ont pas su nous non je
fais partie ont pas su expliquer ont pas
su avoir le bon langage pour intéresser
les gens ou encore de montrer un peu de
manière plus visuel toutes ces
découvertes ou ses algorithmes tous ses
théorèmes qui finalement je pense que
quand c'est bien expliqué intéresse tout
le monde
comme disait georges braque qui était un
peintre et sculpteur français du xxème
siècle l'art trouble la science rassure
si mon intervention nous a permis de
voir que finalement l'art et la science
c'était un petit peu de perception qu'on
avait mais qui fait pas qu'ils font
partie de la même équation
je pense que j'ai réussi ma mission et
si on va tous ensemble après boire un
coup et qu'on en discute
je pense qu'on pourra créer aussi un
nouveau réseau qu'on pourra mettre après
en lumière je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]